we have seen a massive surge in hatred
mail under the Trump administration if
you've never heard hatred mail before
it's when a deep voice movie announcer
reads the hate mail that I get here's a
little preview because the government
that is supposedly totally inept
is the same government that can pull off
a conspiracy that'll blow your mind
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom okay so before we get
into this week's hatred mail very quick
note those little intros that you here
before hatred mail if you want to
contribute one to the show we are
recording new hatred mail intros in that
style that you just heard okay you write
it you send it to me david at david
pakman.com hatred mail guy will voice it
over okay so please send them in they
tend to be about 25 seconds long total
so we want something like you know 21 22
seconds of narration to keep it the same
duration david at david pakman.com
script your own hatred mail intro i
recommend listening to some of the ones
that we have we want to keep it in that
style and get them an exciting
opportunity to contribute to hatred mail
not by calling me horrible names okay
but because that often is what hatred
mail is let's now get into this week's
hatred mail one of Pat's favorites of
all time
[Music]
David NPC Pakman is a proud beta loser
NPC it's not even in accurate
description of Backman he is a Jew which
is way worse than being a NPC really
struck a never with sniveling slimy
girly man David I exclusively date women
Pakman hillary won the popular vote what
is it about this one pat that you love
soma I mean there's there's NPC there's
anti Semitism there's sort of a
masculine and homophobia there are
misspellings there are grant it really
has everything you know yeah well just
the idea that Jews can't be NPCs I think
I I speak for a lot of people and I say
that Jews can certainly be NPCs and
maybe the hate reott will one day call
you one and then also Hillary won the
popular vote like yeah she did happy why
would why would he even mention that I
think it was sarcasm because I think it
can you even put it back up on the
screen briefly I think what their what
the hatred is doing is they're saying
David I exclusively date women Pakman as
if that's not true right that's the
homophobia I'm lying about the fact that
I exclusively date women and that is
just as true as Hillary won the popular
vote like I think the idea and I know
that the Wright doesn't understand nor
are they able to use satire I think the
idea is that they're sort of saying in
the same way that it's a lie that I
exclusively date women it's also a lie
that Hillary Clinton won the popular
vote I'm trying to get into the mind of
the hatred here but that's what I think
they're doing I think I just learned
something here today and I think that we
all learn something so this is
definitely one of my favorite hey treat
male is of all time and I'm looking
forward to next week's one oh hey tree
at 40 hey tree at 40 is the coupon code
if you want to make 302 hey tree it's
cry send them a middle finger every time
a new member signs up on our website
using the coupon code hey tree at 40
more than 300 hey tree it's cry and by
the way that's about the number of
hatred male episodes we've had about 300
stunning we'll be doing something
related to that very soon